bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 78 weekend une
émission consacrée à vos loisirs et à
vos idées de sorties pour ce weekend
deux invités pour m'accompagner bonjour
bonjour avec nous avec vous nous allons
parler de fêtes d'animation à La
Verrière mais aussi d'art contemporain
dans tout le département mais avant cela
direction Guill encour jusqu'au 19 juin
la salle des expositions accueille les
œuvres des participants des ateliers
d'art plastique de la ville une
opportunité pour ces artistes amateurs
de présenter leur travail au public
Aurélia debusi et Elodie
moine peinture sculpture gravure ou
encore photographie les 130 œuvres
présentées par la salle des expositions
de guyoncour ont toutes un point commun
elles sont réalisé par des artistes
amateurs de la ville sortie d'atelier
l'exposition annuelle des ateliers d'art
plastique guyant Courtois est l'occasion
pour les enfants et adultes participants
d'exposer leurs travaux réalisés pendant
l'année ça fait une dizaine d'années que
l'exposition sorti d'atelier clos
toujours la programmation de la salle
d'exposition de guancour ça présente
vraiment la variété de toutes les la
pratique amateur à gu encour cette année
en particulier on a la chance d'avoir
des œuvres de d'enfants qui sont en fait
qui ont travaillé sur la ville ce sont
des fresques collectives au total 42
adultes et 44 enfants exposent leurs
œuvres des pièces uniques à découvrir
jusqu'au 19
juin on s'arrête à présent sur un
événement une première ce weekend le
weekend de l'art contemporain dans les
Yvelines il démarre ce vendredi et dure
jusquau jusau dimanche 15 juin 12 lieux
d'expositions vous sont ouverts tout le
weekend pour en parler avec nous en
plateau Laura Vedel vous êtes chargé de
mission à la Direction des Archives du
patrimoine de l'archéologie et de la
culture du conseil général des ivblines
alors quel est le principe alors le le
principe en fait c'est qu'on est parti
du constat que les ivelines ont beaucoup
de centres d'art il y a beaucoup de
manifestations et d'initiatives autour
de l'art contemporain elles sont très
nombreuses et le département a souhaité
les valoriser et cette valorisation en
fait passe par l'organisation d'un d'une
première édition du weekend de l'art
contemporain qui rassemble ces
initiatives qui les fédère et donc 12
lieux ont accepté de de rejoindre la
manifestation ces 12 lieux en fait sont
font partie d'un réseau un peu informel
qui s'est créé au fil du temps au fil
des initiatives et et ce réseau a
souhaité en fait faire découvrir l'art
contemporain partager en fait l'idée de
démocratisation de la culture et cette
démocratisation de la culture on la
partage c'est une valeur qu'on a en
commun avec avec le entre nos
partenaires et nous pour rendre l'art
contemporain et la culture au sens
général accessible c'est des œuvres à la
fois extérieur et intérieure il y a de
tout exactement il y a il y en a pour
tous les goût pour tous les goûts près
de chez soi loin de chez soi pour
découvrir des territoires qu'on ne
connaît pas c'est à la fois des
expositions intérieures et extérieures
donc on peut on peut on peut trouver
tout ce qui nous plaît et alors c'est la
première édition oui c'est la première
édition d'où d'où ça vient alors d'où ça
vient ça vient de de d'autres
manifestations qui avaient lieu
précédemment qui s'appelent balade en
ieline et qui qui avait permis de faire
ces ces acteurs petit à petit en fait
s'est constitué une un rassemblement
d'acteurs ou de l'art contemporain
autour autour d'une volonté d'exposer
démocratiser l'art contemporain au plus
grand nombre et et donc on a souhaité
effectivement pour pour cette pour cet
été 2014 se rassembler autour de cette
initiative et donc nos 12 lieux
partenaires euh sont très nombreux en
fait et et sont sont des univers très
différents il y a des musées des centres
d'art notamment justement donc là on VO
on voit les photos quelques quelques res
qui seront présenté ce weekend donc ça
se déroule dans tout le département
est-ce que vous pouvez nous citer
quelques quelques exemples de de lieux
d'exposition qu'on pour pour ne fâcher
personne je vais les citer tous très
rapidement donc on a en centre d'art et
en musée il y a le knaay à Chatou il y a
également le microonde avéisi la Tanerie
à Oudan la graineerie à ouille la
maréchalerie à versaill et sur la
communauté d'aglo le musée de C an vine
et la commanderie des Templiers nous
avons également des lieux de patrimoine
très très emblématiques comme la ville
la Savoie le château de la Madeline à
Chevreuse
ou encore l'hospice à char l'aroni une
maison des illustres à saintarnant
Nivine celle d's triol Aragon et pour
finir ma liste à la prév une initiative
municipale qui en a sa 10e édition qui
est sculpture en Lille à andraisie très
bien on va s'arrêter peut-être sur
quelques uns de de ces lieux notamment
la commanderie des Templiers est en
cours qu'est-ce qu'on pourra y trouver
sur alors vous pourrez découvrir une
exposition qui s'appelle le cabinet de
curiosité de Monsieur
Z je ne vais pas en dévoiler beaucoup
parce que il faut il faut la découvrir
elle est pleine de surprises en fait en
fait un monsieur Z est un artiste qui
qui a réinventé des conttes et des
légendes donc c'est unz anthropologique
vous pourriez vous croire au kbran l
mais vous n'y êtes pas il y a plein d'
histoires qu'on vous raconte je dirai
pas plus puisque c'est c'est à découvrir
je vaux laisser le mystère plané voilà
on va laisser les les gens découvrir on
passe du côté de Montin le Bretonneux le
musée de la ville participe aussi à
cette cet événement le musé de la ville
participe aussi bah avec les expositions
qui sont en cours c'estd plastique
plastock et une exposition qui retrace
l'histoire du de la street culture sur
la communauté d'agglomération euh à
Versailles maintenant les anciennes
écuries du château de Versailles alors
dans les anciennes écuries se trouve un
centre d'art particulier c'est celui de
de l'École Nationale d'Architecture de
Versailles qui s'appelle la maréchalerie
donc là vous pourriz découvrir une
proposition qui s'appelle architecture
d'urgence qui est qui est faite par un
artiste qui s'appelle de clerc et qui
qui en fait traite d'une qui traite du
lien entre et architecture et qui
s'inspire en fait de d'une initiative de
Jean Prouvé de 1944 sur l'architecture
d'urgence comment comment on va comment
on peut reloger toutes les personnes
d'après guerre donc il y a un lien entre
art architecture comment l'artiste voit
l'habitat qui qui est très intéressante
est-ce que c'est accessible à tout types
de public parce qu'il y a certaines
choses qui ont l'air un peu quand même
plus évolué que que d'autres est-ce que
les enfants peuventors oui les enfants
peuvent les enfants peuvent participer
il y a certains certains lieux qui
proposent des ateliers notamment qui
sont accessibles enfants la ville la
Savoie propose des visites guidées pour
les enfants le knaille à Chatou propose
un atelier de pratique artistique autour
de de l'artiste Jeff graaz donc il y a
il y a pas mal de choses pour tous les
goûts pour tous les publics très bien
est-ce que vous avez quelques petits
parcours type à nous proposer parce
qu'il y tellement lieux beauou ça va
être difficile alors effectivement ça
être l'occasion d'allier en fait la
découverte du territoire donc ça peut
être l'occasion autour de chez soi
d'aller à Versailles sur le territoire
de Saint-Quentin ou ou encore à véisier
en découvrant les quatre lieux
d'exposition ou alors il est aussi
possible de se créer un parcours autour
du street art en allant notamment au
musée de la ville ou aux hospice
Saint-Charles qu' on a vu rapidement ou
ici encore effectivement le la
proposition de Speedy grafito à la
maison alatriolé ou alors il est
possible aussi de découvrir les
magnifiques paysages que nous avons sur
les bords de scèes en partant de Chatou
jusqu'à jusqu'à Rony en passant par
poissti Andr et la et ouille ou alors de
découvrir nos nos belles campagnes
vinoises en allant de la Chevreuse
jusqu'à ouans on voyage on voyage on
découvre les ivelines en se cultivant
super c'est important de savoir
également est-ce que c'est gratuit alors
sont presque toutes gratuites en accès
libre sauf la maison à atriux l'Aragon
et la Villa sa voie à poissie est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment aujourd'hui que
l'art contemporain justement a besoin
d'événements comme ça que c'est encore
taxé de d'inaccessible de effectivement
l'art contemporain peut encore sembler
élitiste mais je vous laisse découvrir
la proposition de l'artiste Laurent
Lacotte à la graine tri ou qui justement
réfléchit sur ces questions
d'accessibilité à l'art
contemporain je le je le rappelle donc
le weekend de l'art contemporain dans
les Yveline c'est du 13 au 15 juin et
c'est dans tout le département toutes
les informations s'affichent en bas de
votre écran merci lur Vedel merci alors
on passe maintenant à la danse Nicolas
Gervet a rencontré cette semaine la
chorégraphe Maria Mendy qui nous
présente son spectacle NOPA dantpa il
sera présenté le 24 juin à la ferme de
bbas à guillencour dans le cadre d'une
soirée consacré à la famille voici un
extrait de Le
rencontre chorégraphe et danseuse j'ai
monté ma propre
association assation jade en
1996 et euh depuis ça fait que évoluer
j'ai pas mal d'élèves dans des styles
différents danse africaine hip hop
afrojzz break j'ai monter au sein de
cette association un atelier
chorégraphique avec les danseurs qui me
suivaient le mieux euh qui assurit aussi
le mieux on a passé pas mal de concours
et cetera où on a été lauréa souvent et
puis du coup j'ai décidé de monter une
compagnie le duo il a été il a été pensé
au moment du décès de mon père en fait
il a septembre ça va faire 2 ans le
théâre de B et bas m'appelle en me
disant voilà mari on a une proposition à
te faire est-ce que tu aurais quelque
chose à présenter au théâtre sauf que
cette proposition arrivait pour moi pas
au bon moment parce que j'étais vraiment
pas bien par rapport à cette histoire
et je me sentais pas capable j'avais pas
envie de créer quelque chose de noir
euh raconter ma vie par rapport au décès
de mon père et en même temps je me suis
dit purée euh c'est une super
opportunité le théâtre je peux pas
passer à côté voilà je leur ai demandé
de me laisser un peu de temps j'ai
répondu ok mais ce serait une création
euh concernant le décès de mon
père allez on poursuit ce 78 weekend
avec une autre idée de sortie ce samedi
à La Verrière la ville organise sa sa
traditionnelle fête de juin dès 15h pour
en parler avec nous Samuel Denis vous
êtes le directeur du scarabé à La
Verrière alors ça commence demain le
samedi 14 juin qu'est-ce que c'est alors
la fête de la ville ou fête de juin
parce qu'il a deux appellations jamais
bien compris la quelle éta la Bonn les
deux fonctionnent c'est tous les 3è
samedi du mois de juin donc déjà il y a
erreur cette année puisqu'on est le 2e
en fait sinon c'était le 21 juin et pour
éviter la concurence des fêtes de la
musique qui est à droite à gauche donc
quand ça tombe le 21 on la met le 14
mais sinon c'est bien le 3e samedi de
chaque chaque mois de juin donc c'est
une grande fête sur la plouse devant le
scarabé et en fait c'est toutes les
associations donc cette année il y a 24
stands 24 stands associatifs qui
viennent présenter leur letion voà
Vinent présenter leurs activités
respectives vendre aussi pour certains
un peu à boire un peu à manger pour
faire un petit peu un petit peu de sous
pour l'association et toute la journée
est ponctuée donc de 15h jusqu'à minuit
et ponctué de d'animations qui sont
proposé soit par les associations
locales euh donc des troupes amateurs
euh soit des une programmation
professionnelle que j'établis moi au
même titre que je fais la programmation
du scarabé je fais donc la programmation
de la fête de la ville on va dire les
professionnels sont plus sur la soirée
bien et puis enfin voilà il y a un petit
mix parce que là cette année il y a un
petit on fait mentir la règle il y a
aussi des animations professionnelles
l'après-midi c'est c'est une tradition
ça fait longtemps que vous l'organisez
chaque année alors vous disiez il y aura
tout donc des stands associatifs des
spectacles des animations mais aussi des
déambulations musicale avec notamment
dès 16h30 il y a un groupe de
professionnel il s'appelle garçon s'il
vous plaît oui garçon s'il vous plaît
que j'ai découvert sur un festival en
septembre dernier voilà c'est trois
trois garçons de café enfin habillé
comme tel en tout cas garçon de café la
petite serviette le petit plateau et qui
transporte une ardoise une grande
ardoise où il y a une cinquantaine de
titres de chansons ils peuvent vous
croiser dans la fête s'arrêter devant
vous avec leur ardoise et puis nous dire
qu'est-ce que vous voulez entendre donc
voilà les gens choisissent une chanson
et hop ils se mettent en place ils ont
toujours un petit scén ario très rapide
ils ont des petits instruments
acoustiques qui sont accrochés à leur
ceinture ils déganent leurs instruments
et hop ils vous font le morceau ça peut
être pour une personne pour 10 pour 20
soit ils vont à une terrasse soit ils se
promènent dans la fête c'est de la
diambulation et ils chantent devant qui
ils ont envie de chanter peut-être des
gens peuvent effectivement le dire
garçon c'est ça garçon s'il vous plaît
moi je veux bien une chanson il vienent
vous chanter une chanson de votre choix
et bien je propose de regarder ce que ça
donne avec un petit
extrait
alors un tout autre groupe que l'on pour
rrouver cette fois plus à la tombée de
la nuit en soirée c'est baluche de la
saugrenue alors CIN musiciens qui
proposent différents styles de musique
ça c'est le c'est ce qui remplace la
grande scène qu'on avait habituellement
où il y avait donc un concert de de fin
de soirée là c'est donc des musiciens
qui sont dans une caravane qui est coupé
sur en travers et donc voilà il nous
propose ce qu'onelle le baluche de la
saugrenue c'est un bal kitch alternatif
assumé voilà on est dans un mélange du
buches des années 30 avec de la musique
d'hier et d'aujourd'hui tout ça bien
mixé ensemble on trrouve un peu les
ambiances parisienne voilà on va mettre
des petites ampoules de couleur autour
on va mettre des petites terrasses donc
ça fait guinguette et en même temps ils
sont pas dans la musique rétro c'est
l'esprit des années 30 avec de la
musique d'aujourd'hui quoi donc ça
devrait être bien sympathique et donc il
joue de jusqu'à jusqu'à presque minuit
en fait on va voir un petit extrait
également mon cor devient sour je suis
pas bien dans mes que j'en rve fantasque
je découpe mes culotes extring ma crou
je découpe mon corps ma mort la mode me
voudrait fine je mange j'engrange dé
poubelle et merde j'ai encore retrouvé
un mic mac dans mes selles je m pour les
petites Bou je m tellement à ma famille
alors au niveau des animations donc il y
aura un peu de tout pour tous les âges
tout le monde peut y venir il y a pas de
voilà de de de 15h à à enfin les
animations sur la fête proposée par les
assauts sont de 15h à 19h
19h 19h 19h15 alors il y a notamment une
activité plutôt originale moi je ne
connaissais pas le snack line snack line
ouais qu'est-ce que c'est le snack l
donc ça c'est une une
sangle environ 10 cm qui est tendue
entre deux arbres mais quand je dis
tendu c'est extrêmement tendu et donc il
a on a un spécialiste là qui a un très
bon niveau au niveau national à la
verrière donc il va nous faire une
démonstration ils font des figures sur
cette au lieu d'être un fil c'est pas
des fil de feriste c'est il est sur sur
la sangle en fait il fait des des
pirouettes des enfin il y a plein de
plein de figures qui sont effectuées sur
cette sangle et va y avoir aussi une
plus petite sangle qui va être tendue où
là il y aura de l'initiation pour ceux
qui veulent s'essayer ça paraît simple
comme ça à voir mais à faire c'est c'est
très compliqué ou il faut être donc on a
la chance d'avoir quelqu'un qui a un bon
niveau à La Verrière donc qui va nous
nous nous montrer et puis après nous
expliquer comment comment on peut
essayer nous-même quoi très bien il y a
d'autres activités un peu oui il y a il
y a des une association de prévention
qui propose des T en poney pour alors
c'est la seule activité payante
d'ailleurs ce sera 2 € le tour de poney
c'est pour financer un projet cirque
avec des jeunes tout le reste est
gratuit tout le reste est gratuit alors
il y a une petite tombola avec le
Secours populaire je crois ça une
tombola à priori on une petite pièce il
y a une initiative originale cette année
des Restos du cœur avec une halte bébé
c'està dire qu' y a un stand qui voilà
si vous avez il leschau bibron il y aura
table àonger il y aura un départ avant
pour faire ça tranquille derrière et
donc voilà plutôt que de rentrer avec
bébé à la maison parce que c'est l'heure
de manger ou l'heure de le changer ça
pourrait être fait en direct sur la fête
donc ça c'est une initiative nouvelle ça
existait pas les années précédentes et
puis différents jeux voilà tout
l'après-midi on a on a une petite
piscine de 5 m par 5 m avec 30 cm d'eau
et six petits bateaux télécommandés
dessus avec des postes de commande on
espérant que le soleil soit au
rendez-vous ouais ouais ou oui il nous
annonce peut-être 50 % de chance de
petite P après-midi on espère que non
euh j'ai vu démo de graphe également
qu'est-ce que c'est oui ça c'est
l'association des Jack Tigers donc une
nouvelle association à la verrière qui
vont proposer une prestade de daner eux
qui ouv la fête à 15h sur le le plancher
bois puisque le plancher bois du soir du
bal va servir aussi à présenter des
animations l'après-midi et donc voilà
ils ont des des antennes de leur
association qui sont grafeeurs et donc
il vont venir faire une alors on a
imaginé à un moment faire démonstration
et aussi initiation mais initiation
grave c'est un peu compliqué quoi faut
mett les masques les tenues tout ça donc
ça va juste être une démonstration ils
vont nous faire une il y a deux band
rolles de de 5 m par 1 m et donc voilà
ils vont les décorer tout l'après-midi
enfin les décorer les grafés et
peut-être si elles sont très jolies on
les gardera on les affichera sur la
façade du scarabé peut-être un jour et
alors pour ceux qui veulent en profiter
jusqu'au bout de la nuit à minuit vous
prévoyez un lâcher de lanterne céleste
ça c'est la clôture de la fête cette
année ouais donc c'est des c'est des
alors on dit lanterne céleste ou
lanterne chinoise ou lanterne volante
enfin c'est des des trucs d'un m sur 1 m
des grandes houles avec une une mèche à
l'intérieur et on la porte on l'allume
mais VO ça fait comm une molfière ça
s'envole et donc ça monte ça monte ça
monte et ça finit par
disparaître il faut pas de vent faut pas
plus de 15 km he de vent sinon elle
monte et puis elle va dans l'arbre du
voisin quoi donc là c'est pas ça c'est
pas bon donc donc ça aura lieu si si le
vent est inférieur à 15 km/h ça c'est
pas gagné très bien et bien je le je le
rappelle donc la fête du 2 juin à La
Verrière c'est ce samedi rendez-vous dès
15h donc sur la pelouse du scarabé ouis
merci à vous et donc normalement c'est
pas moi qui devait venir puisquil y a
éice du jardin qui est la la grande
prêtresse de la fête de la ville cette
année donc voilà je suis venu à sa place
je lui fais un petit clin d'œil et puis
j'en profite donc au clin d'œil je vais
en faire aussi un à Makati et puis au
trio euh Juliette Cendrine Lara voilà
euh merci de m'avoir invité pour parler
de la villeci vous d'êt venu sur le
plateau allez on se dirige maintenant à
éloncour il y a quelques jours la
compagnie d'arc organisé un concours
extérieur sélectif pour les championnats
de France parmi les 400 archers présents
la nouvelle championne du monde Sophie
dodémon venue décocher quelques flèches
Anthony rche et CLA Cambier
depuis son titre mondial anime il y a de
mois Sophie d'udemont est désormais très
attendu sur les pas de tir c'est la
fierté du pays elle est reconnue à
l'international elle gagne tous les
concours qu'elle fait première mondiale
enfin surtout qu' pas était encore
classique tout de suite première saison
en arcoulé elle a battu tout le monde à
40 ans et pour seulement sa deuxème
saison en arcapouli Sophie de deemont a
décoché son premier titre international
et a enchaîné il y a 3 semaines en
battant le record d'Europe du nombre de
points inscrits en extérieur aujourd'hui
je me pose la question qu'est-ce qui
manque encore comme tout sportif à un
certain niveau c'est vrai que voilà moi
en classique j'ai fait du classique
avant je suis médaille olympique ma
carrière sportif commence à être bien
rempli et ça fait plaisir malgré cette
excellence la sociétaire du club de
viler Lebelle n'est pas parvenu à se
qualifi pour les phases finales des
dernières étapes de Coupe du Monde une
preuve du niveau du plateau
international actuel aujourd'hui on est
vraiment sur un tir de précision surtout
en arcapoui quand on voit les hommes sur
des matchs ils font 150 sur 150 à 50 m
ils sont départagés à la plus belle
flèche au centre on se dit mais c'est
c'est super impressionnant membre de
l'équipe de France depuis 25 ans Sophie
de Demont semble bien décidé à ne pas
ranger ses flèches et tire désormais
après le record du monde du nombre de
points et avant de nous quitter place au
traditionnel agenda du weekend avec vos
idées sorties alors nous avons parlé de
celle de la verrière mais d'autres
communes organisent également leurs
fêtes ce weekend notamment à saint-sire
l'école cette année la ville se
transforme en village du Far West pour
célébrer le western vous aurez
l'occasion de découvrir le spectacle
extrême rodéo show un spectacle dans
lequel chevaux indomtabl et taureaux
surpuissants seront les vedettes
d'autres spectacles et animations sont
bien sûr au programme rendez-vous aux
alentour de 15h au parc Maurice Leluc de
saint-sire à rambouiller maintenant
l'exposition vie SAU vie domestique une
exposition qui vous permet d'approcher
les animaux domestiques à l'entrée du
parc puis d'observer les sangliers les
seres ou encore les biches au sein de la
forêt c'est samedi 14 et dimanchees 15
juin à partir de 14h pour plus
d'informations n'hésitez pas à aller
voir le programme sur le site internet
et parce qu'il serait dommage de ne pas
profiter du beau temps voici une
activité de pleinir ludique et originale
l'Urban golf la différence avec la
discipline traditionnelle c'est le
terrain tout simplement puisque celle-ci
se pratiquera ce weekend tout près du
centre commercial autour de l'espace
Saint-Quentin et dans le parc des
sources de la Bièvre du sport toujours
et du football américain l'équipe élite
des Templiers d'élancour défend sa place
en première division face au spariat
Damien ce weekend coup d'envoi samedi 14
juin d 15h au complexe sportif voilà de
quoi bien occuper vos weekends c'est la
fin de cette édition merci de l'avoir
suivi je vous souhaite un excellent
weekend